from David Goggins it's so easy to be
great because most of the world is weak
if you are even remotely a Savage you
will run these people over it's all out
there for the taking right now Dana
White everyone rails against the victim
mentality that seems to be sweeping
certain areas of the world I get it you
don't want your town or country or
species to go to hell because everyone
has forgotten how to take some
discomfort or deal with challenges in
life but on another hand this rampant
fragility is your competitive Advantage
the bar has never been set lower a bit
of consistency tensionality resilience
and a gram of talent will make you into
an absolute killer I also understand
that you probably want to raise other
people up along with you having a
greatness stand on the shoulders of the
world's fragility may seem exploitative
and I love the idea of not just
improving yourself but changing those
around you for the better but there's a
limit your efforts are multiplied by 10
times when building with the right
people and by 0.01 times when building
with the wrong people if someone refuses
to alter their habits or update their
worldview or improve their life despite
being given all of the tools and
encouragement they need by you then they
can stay where they are it is not your
job to drown Yourself by trying to keep
others afloat who don't want to change